>>> DONALD TRUMP IS COMPARING
THE UNPRECEDENTED FBI SEARCH OF
HIS MAR-A-LAGO ESTATE TO THE
1972 BREAK-IN AT THE WATERGATE
HOTEL.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT ASKED THIS,
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THIS AND WATERGATE?
WHERE OPERATIVES BROKE INTO THE
DEMOCRAT NATIONAL COMMITTEE.
HERE IN REVERSE, DEMOCRATS BROKE
INTO THE HOME OF THE 45th
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
LET'S EXPLAIN THE DIFFERENCE.
THE WATERGATE BREAK-IN WAS
ILLEGAL.
A BURGLARY BY NIXON HENCHMAN.
THE MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH WAS
CONDUCTED BY KFBI AGENTS WHO
KNOCKED ON THE DOOR AND HAD A
JUDGE WHO SAID THERE WAS
PROBABLE CAUSE THAT THERE WAS
ILLEGALLY ACTIVITY AT THE
PRESIDENT'S HOME.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH JOHN DEAN.
JOHN, TRUMP LIKES TO MAKE
HISTORICAL COMPARISONS.
HE LIKES TO PLAY VICTIM.
ON THE FACTS HERE, HE'S FLAT OUT
WRONG, RIGHT?
>> HE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENED DURING WATERGATE OR
HE'S JUST TRYING TO DISTORT WHAT
HAPPENED THERE AT HIS HOME.
AND IT DOESN'T WORK AT ALL, THE
ANALOGY.
>> AND SO WALK ME THROUGH YOUR
THOUGHTS.
YOU KNOW, YOU GET INTERVIEWED
ALL THE TIME ABOUT YOUR DAYS IN
NIXON.
YOU'RE A FORMER WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL.
A PRETTY SMART LEGAL MIND.
THAT THE FBI AND THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WOULD SIGN OFF
ON A WARRANT FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO GO SEARCH HIS RESIDENCE IN
FLORIDA, WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU
ABOUT THE STATE OF THIS
INVESTIGATION?
>> IT TELLS ME, JOHN, THAT THEY
WERE COOPERATING BUT SOMEHOW
TRUMP CUT THEM OFF AND DID
SOMETHING THAT PROVOKED THIS
ACTION.
THEY OBVIOUSLY ARE VERY AWARE OF
WHAT HE HAS.
THEY MAY HAVE AN INSIDE SOURCE
THAT SEES SOME ABUSE OF THAT
MATERIAL.
SO THEY HAD TO TAKE AN
EXTRAORDINARY ACTION TO PROTECT
THE NATIONAL SECURITY DOCUMENTS.
THAT APPEARS WHAT THIS IS.
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES IS VERY
AGGRESSIVE WITH THIS SORT OF
THING.
I KNOW A FORMER NIXON WHITE
HOUSE AIDE WHO HAPPENED TO NOT
GET ALL HIS PAPERS TURNED IN,
LATER COOPERATED WITH A
JOURNALIST ON A BOOK, NEXT
MORNING, THE FBI WAS AT HIS
DOOR.
AND IT WAS NOT A FRIENDLY VISIT.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THEY'RE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
NATIONAL SECURITY INFORMATION
AND PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ARE NOT
WHERE THEY SHOULD BE.
>> SO TAKE US BACK THROUGH YOUR
EXPERIENCE AND CONNECT THE DOTS
WHERE YOU CAN AND MAKE IMPORTANT
D
DISTINCTIONS IN THE SENSE OF THE
INVESTIGATION OF NIXON TOOK A
LONG TIME.
THERE WERE TAPES THAT TURNED UP,
DOCUMENTS, BUT THE BUILDING
BLOCKS OF THAT TOOK SOME TIME.
WHEN YOU'RE WATCHING THIS PLAY
OUT TODAY, WHAT SEEMS FAMILIAR
AND WHAT IS DIFFERENT?
>> WELL, WHEN MY FIRST REACTION
WHEN I HEARD ABOUT THE SERVING
THE SEARCH WARRANT, I FIGURED
WHICH INVESTIGATION IS THIS THAT
THEY THINK THEY HAVE DOCUMENTS?
IT WASN'T UNTIL LATER AND
ACTUALLY IN TRUMP'S RESPONSE
WHEN HE SAID HILLARY CLINTON GOT
AWAY WITH HER EMAILS, I SAID,
UH-UH, HE IS DEALING WITH
DOCUMENTS THAT ARE MISSING AND
HASN'T TURNED IN OR SOMETHING OF
THAT NATURE.
THIS HAS BEEN MONTHS IN
DEVELOPMENT.
YOU HAVE AN AGENCY THAT IS VERY
PROTECTIVE OF ITS DOCUMENTS.
AND WANTS THEM AND WANTS -- THIS
IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE TO MAKE A
POINT THAT NOT EVEN A FORMER
PRESIDENT CAN WALK OFF WITH
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
IF YOU RECALL SANDY BERGER, WHO
WAS BILL CLINTON'S NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER, WENT OUT AND
TRIED TO TAKE SOME DOCUMENTS
FROM THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
AND HE GOT -- HE DIDN'T GO TO
JAIL FOR IT, BUT HE GOT A HEAVY
FINE.
THE JUDGE FINED HIM $50,000, AND
REALLY SCOLDED HIM BECAUSE IT
WAS A STUPID THING HE DID.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUED.
IT APPEARS TO BE SEPARATE FROM
TRUMP'S MANY OTHER PROBLEMS.
BUT WHILE THEY WERE THERE AND
SERVING THAT SUBPOENA, IF THEY
SAW ANYTHING THAT RELATED TO HIS
INVOLVEMENT IN THE OVERTURN OF
THE ELECTION, THEY COULD TAKE
THAT.
SO WE DON'T KNOW, AND WHAT TRUMP
SHOULD DO IS TURN OVER AND OPEN
UP THE WARRANT AND LET US ALL
SEE WHAT THEY WANTED.
>> IT WOULD BE GREAT TO SEE WHAT
THEY WANTED.
I'M SURE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
WANT TO WAIT.
BEFORE I LET YOU GO, IT'S HARD
FOR ME TO BELIEVE, WE'RE HAVING
THIS CONSAG 48 YEARS TO THE DAY
OF RICHARD NIXON LEAVING THE
WHITE HOUSE.
48 YEARS AGO IN THIS HOUR,
GERALD FORD BEING SWORN IN AS
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
WHAT GOES THROUGH YOUR MIND?
>> WELL, WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT
THAT WE WOULD HAVE A PRESIDENT
THAT IS MORE TROUBLESOME THAN
RICHARD NIXON?
I NEVER DREAMED SOMEONE WOULD
MAKE HIM LOOK LIKE A CHOIR BOY,
BUT HERE WE ARE.
HE LOOKS AWFULLY GOOD TODAY, AS
OPPOSED TO THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE
WITH TRUMP.
>> JOHN DEAN, GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY.
I REMEMBER SITTING WITH MY
FATHER, 10 YEARS OLD ON THIS
DAY, BACK WHEN THIS HAPPENED.
HE SAID THINGS ABOUT RICHARD
NIXON I WILL NOT SAY ON LIVE